NICK ORLOFF: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to CE Chat.
We are graciously hosted by
the Cloud OnAir team, who host
these amazing weekly webinars.
So definitely make sure you tune
in to Cloud OnAir every week.
My name is Nick Orloff,
and I'm a customer engineer
at Google Cloud.
And today, I'm
absolutely thrilled
to have one of the rock star
product managers of Google,
Prajakta Joshi.
Prajakta, you want to
introduce yourself?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sure.
Thanks, Nick.
Hi, everyone.
Really excited to be here.
I work in cloud networking.
I'm a product manager there.
I work on several
networking products,
including load balancing CDN
and others, but most interested
to be here today to talk
to you about Cloud Armor.
NICK ORLOFF: Yeah, absolutely.
You know, security
is always top of mind
for every one of our customers.
Whether you are a small startup
or a massive enterprise,
security is absolutely
foundational to your success
as a business.
And one of the unique
things that Google brings
to our customers is that Google
is a tried and true player
in this market, and
we obviously see
these kinds of security
threats, vulnerabilities,
from end to end.
And so our approach to security,
since we've done this before,
is to absolutely trust nothing.
That's really how everything
can be boiled down.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's right.
NICK ORLOFF: And the
way that we approach
security is very defense
in depth matters.
Rather than just
protecting the perimeter,
we really protect all layers
of the security stacks.
So whether that means using our
custom built hardware that's
in our data centers
too IM security
permissions for your end users,
security keys, encryption keys,
we really make
sure that your data
that is being sent
to Google Cloud
is being protected end to end.
And today, I'm really
excited because we
get to talk about the
subjects of the application
and the network itself,
because those are
very, very critical components.
So Prajakta, can you run
us through some of that?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sure, happy to.
So as Nick mentioned, at
Google, one of the first things
that we do is we
trust nothing, which
means that you have to secure
everything in the stack.
And as we start talking
about network security,
it is very critical to secure
every path, every resource,
and every access that can happen
when you're actually running
your services inside Google
Cloud or even on prem,
accessing it from
elsewhere and so on.
Now if you look
here, what you notice
is that there are several paths.
First of all, you have
your VPCs and Google Cloud,
and you would typically
use a firewall,
so these are our distributed
firewalls that run on the host.
If you're connecting,
let's say from on prem,
or even if you're
accessing any of the Google
services, such as Google Cloud
Storage, BigQuery, and so on,
there is another feature called
VPC service controls, which
helps you with access
control to that.
But one of the areas that
is typically of concern
to almost everyone who's
delivering internet
facing services is, how
to mitigate and defend
against denial of
service attacks,
and how to protect your
internet facing applications
from getting attacked or even
just from unauthorized access
as well.
NICK ORLOFF: Absolutely.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So most of
what we're going to talk
about today is related
to that, and that's
where, first of all, our network
and some of the other products,
including Cloud Armor,
come in the picture.
NICK ORLOFF: Great.
I'm excited.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So you
know, the other day
we were talking about the
denial of service attacks.
And a good way to
essentially slice
these denial of service
attacks is, think of them
as being in separate buckets.
The first one is the
infrastructure DDoS attacks.
So this is where an attacker
will try and send you
huge volumes of traffic
and will try and overwhelm
your application.
So examples include TCP
SYN floods, DNS, NTP
and other amplification
attacks, things
such as IP fragmentation
attacks and so on.
These literally require tons and
tons of bandwidth to mitigate.
Now, there's another
more sophisticated form
of attacks, which are called
application-aware attacks.
These not necessarily
depend on volume,
but they depend on being
aware of the application
and then exploiting the
weakness of the application.
So examples would be Slowloris,
cross-site scripting,
SQL injection, and so on.
And then the last one would
be, a lot of these attackers
are very sophisticated,
and they're essentially
combining multiple
types of attacks,
and then that's what we
call the multivector attack.
NICK ORLOFF: I love that
Google is protecting
not only the infrastructure
itself, but also
the applications.
Would you mind going
into, just real briefly,
what cross-site scripting
and SQL injection are?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sure.
So as I mentioned
before, the attacker
depends on knowing something
about the application.
In both cases, the
attacker is trying
to inject some malicious
code and making
that code execute,
because that's
a weakness in the application.
So for example, in
case of SQL injection,
the attacker is trying to
take the flow of the SQL
and trying to execute
queries against the database.
So imagine dumping out the
whole database for the attacker.
That's what you would
do in SQL injection.
In case of cross-site
scripting, similar, but you're
essentially injecting malicious
code and making your browser
execute a set of things
against the application.
So imagine bypassing access
controls, knobs, and so on.
So that's what you would do
with cross-site scripting.
NICK ORLOFF:
Definitely a threat.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: For sure.
So as we started
thinking about, you
know, as we had
our own services,
so we started off with
search, and there's YouTube,
and there's Gmail.
We have about 7 billion
user plus services,
and we definitely
get attacked a lot.
So one of the first
things that we
did as we put these
services in place
is to also build out
the infrastructure
to go defend these services
against our denial of service
attacks.
Now, if you look at the
graph on the screen,
this is a statistic
that is gathered
from all of the
attacks that have been
seen on Google's own services.
A few interesting things
I wanted to point out.
If you notice, the graph
is already in TBPS,
and traditionally you've
seen these graphs in MEPS.
So these attacks have
already surpassed and gone
into the TBPS territory.
So internally, we have
updated all our graphs
to be TBPS driven.
The same increase can be
seen along packets per second
and some of the other
metrics as well.
Actually, do you want
to add something?
NICK ORLOFF: I was
just going to comment
that it's absolutely incredible
that things are scaling
up so quickly now that the
predominance of these attacks
are really growing in scale.
So that's incredible.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's true.
That's true.
And in fact, Damien who is
one of our DDoS defense leads,
he gave me this really
interesting statistic.
He said, you know,
what does a big DDoS
attack feel like, or
look like, or how much
bandwidth does it require.
And he said imagine it's
like basically requiring
the bandwidth needed to
watch half a million YouTube
videos at the same time in HD.
So it is massive
amount of bandwidth
that is needed on the provider
side to go absorb these attacks
and also defend the services
against these attacks as well.
NICK ORLOFF: Yeah.
If you're a startup or
really any size company,
I could see how trying to play
half a million YouTube videos
simultaneously would
bring down your network.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's true.
That's true.
So a lot of times when the
customers are onboarding
into GCP, the first
question they have is,
what are the kind
of protections that
are there, or what are the
products and solutions that
are there, to help defend
their internet facing services?
Think of them as being
in two categories.
The first is a set
products that we ourselves
provide, the first one
being the global network.
We will talk about
it a bit more.
There's the global
Load Balancer.
We have Cloud CDN,
and then Cloud Armor,
which is a product
we launched in March.
We also have an
interesting product
called Identity-aware
Proxy, which we
will talk about soon as well.
And a very interesting
one, along with all of this
is Project Shield,
which is essentially
our pro bono service.
Uses the same
infrastructure, but it's
used for defending journalists
and other folks who
essentially, you know,
are voicing opinions that
would likely be
suppressed, and that's
why they're getting DDoSed.
So they get basically
shielded under Project Shield.
We also have several
partners who provide
capabilities for DDoS defense.
You can see some of them
listed on this screen.
We have a lot more.
So the whole idea is to
give you an arsenal of tools
that you can actually
use to go and build
really comprehensive
protection for your internet
facing services.
So let's maybe walk
through each of these
and dissect them
a little bit more.
NICK ORLOFF: Yeah, absolutely.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
One of the things
that you will typically
hear from customers
who are Google
Cloud customers is,
the biggest reason they chose
Google Cloud is its network.
And when you look
at this diagram,
this is essentially showing
you Google's network.
If you look at all of the
blobs with numbers in it,
those are our regions,
and then the numbers in it
are the number of
zones in that region.
So that's where you'd put
your compute or your storage.
Some of the things that you
mentioned when you were talking
about defense in
depth, the entire stack
is secured when you're
deploying things in here.
The second interesting
bit in here
is, all of those blue lines.
So that's essentially
our network.
This is our backbone.
These are cables,
could be undersea
or could be terrestrial.
The dark gray dots
that you see our pops.
And so the pops are where your
customers come and terminate
their traffic.
And then from there,
they're connected
to the data centers,
the regions and zones
that you see, using
those blue lines.
So those are our cables,
undersea, terrestrial
and so on.
One of the interesting bits
that I also like to tell
is, our network is
also shark-proof.
So this is an actual
picture of-- so when
we looked at those
blue lines, that's
actually one of those cables.
NICK ORLOFF: One of
our undersea cables?
Wow.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: It looks
like the shark was hungry,
but luckily there
was no downtime
on any of the services
being served there.
So it is actually a
pretty phenomenal network,
and it is also one of the
big differentiators as to why
customers come to Google Cloud.
So having this huge
global network,
that's the reason
we can deliver all
of the services that then go and
secure your services as well.
NICK ORLOFF: Awesome.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So we spoke
about the infrastructure.
One of the first
things that customers
who come to Google Cloud do
is turn on the Global Load
Balancer.
Now, if you think of traditional
load balancing, which
is essentially, whether
self-managed or delivered
by third parties, that will
reside inside the data center,
because you're running
it as managed VMs,
or you're running it
as managed containers.
One of the nice things about
our global load balancing,
it is not essentially
delivered through VMs
or through containers, but
it's this massive globally
distributed
infrastructure that sits
at the edge of our network.
And so any time you put
the Global Load Balancer
in front of your
back ends, which
is instances or storage
that's sitting inside our data
centers, you're essentially
stopping the attackers.
You're stopping the
malicious traffic right
at the edge of the
network, and you're
preventing that from
consuming bandwidth
all the way to your back ends.
Of course, this is the same
infrastructure that, again,
defends Google's own services.
So it is battle tested over
the last decade or more.
And the last thing
I wanted to mention
is, Google is a big
believer in TLS everywhere.
And so generally,
we encourage all
of our customers to use TLS.
So you use issue TPS.
For non-issue TP traffic,
we have other flavors
of load balancers
that will support it.
But that is one of the big
things where, you know,
we've always been a big
proponent of TLS everywhere.
We introduced seven new
features to help make that easy.
So things such as SSL
policies, multiple certs,
we don't charge
anything extra for TLS.
So it is a huge driver for you
to go and deploy your services
with encryption turned on.
NICK ORLOFF: That's awesome.
And I know that performance
is very critical to Google,
and so one of the amazing
things that customers
like about our load
balancing solution
is that there is absolutely
no pre-warming required.
Basically, we scale with you
as your traffic scales up.
Very impressive.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yeah, and
I think to your point,
I mean, the reason we
can do all of these
is, these are just architected
to be massively distributive
systems, and they benefit from
economies of scale as well.
So given that, you
know, these can
handle YouTube worth of traffic,
or search worth of traffic,
it is very easy for us to also
provide the same scale or even
the same high availability to
the customers that are actually
going to use this.
NICK ORLOFF: Cool.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Which brings
us to the main topic for today,
which is Cloud Armor.
So we spoke about
the network and we
spoke about the
Global Load Balancer
as being your first
line of defense,
including against
volumetric and protocol
attack, so your
infrastructure DDoS defense.
When we provided these
two, we used to often hear
from our customers.
So is there a way
for me to go put
a blacklist or a white list?
Or can I go control
access to my service
if it's coming
from a certain geo?
Can I go drop that traffic?
Or can you help me put
some sort of WAF rules?
As we started hearing more
and more of those requests,
that is how this product,
Cloud Armor, was born.
We also used to hear
from our partners
about the requirement
for something like this.
We'll deep dive into that.
So again, when we
say whether it's
the global load balance
or our Cloud Armor,
the infrastructure
that is used to deliver
these products
exists, has existed
for decades, a decade or more.
And what we give you is a
way to go and orchestrate
this infrastructure
so you can use it
to protect your own services.
So it's a really
good combination
where you have Google's
global network.
You have the cloud
load balancer.
And then Cloud
Armor is a service
that today is supported with
HTTP/HTTPS load balancer,
will be supported with
other services, as well.
So the other key thing
is it is basically
defense at scale, which
means you don't have
to worry about how
many queries per second
this Cloud Armor
thing can support,
because the thing itself is so
distributed that it will scale
up based on your traffic.
So you don't have to worry about
the HE of Cloud Armor itself.
And then the last
thing we wanted
to build is essentially a
policy-driven framework,
so build a very robust
policy-driven framework
that then you can go build on
to deliver security policies
or block certain type of things,
or even build your own custom
rules, and so on.
So that, in a nutshell,
is Cloud Armor.
One of the things that
I also mentioned briefly
is that it works with the
global HTTP/HTTPS load balancer.
So that's what you
can see in here,
which means that the
infrastructure DDoS
defense is taken care of by
the global HTTP/HTTPS load
balancer.
And then several of
the other capabilities
that we spoke about will be
taken care of by Cloud Armor.
But one of the things I
thought is, it's one thing
to talk about Cloud Armor.
Why don't we go
show it in action?
Should we do that?
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah,
let's do that.
I'm excited.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: OK.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our demo
on denial of service.
Today we're going to show
how a top retailer defends
against denial of
service attack.
Today is Black Friday and
we have some excellent deals
on our web site.
And we have a number of shoppers
who are up early on the morning
to shop on our website.
The boxes represent our happy
shoppers across the globe.
And they're shopping on our
web site and buying products.
Now, if you look at this
one, this is essentially
our shopping app.
And the baskets
essentially are servicing
all of the transactions
that are coming in.
You can see the lovely boxes
floating in across the globe,
coming into our service.
And you can see a
bunch of happy shoppers
who bought some
really great deals.
Here's the thing-- this
is also prime opportunity
for an attacker to go launch
an infrastructure DDoS attack.
Look at the screen.
You can see some really
happy shoppers shopping.
But with infrastructure
DDoS attack,
the attacker sends
in tons and tons
of traffic trying to overwhelm
our shopping service.
And in fact, if you look at
some of the largest attacks
that we've seen
at Google, you can
see that they are increasing
exponentially in volume.
And in fact, if you look
at all of these attacks,
they are like watching half
a million YouTube videos all
at the same time
in high-definition.
Look at those attack
packets coming in.
They would have
totally overwhelmed
our shopping service.
And our shoppers would not
be able to shop at all.
But we were prepared for this.
Prior to Black Friday,
we have deployed
Google global load balancing.
You can see the
beautiful blue ring.
This is Google's
global infrastructure
that's protecting
our shopping app
and making sure that all of
our customers can shop happily.
You can see that all
the infrastructure DDoS
attacks are mitigated, and
we have some happy shoppers.
However, infrastructure
DDoS attacks
are not only attacks
you're going to see.
James?
JAMES: One of the
other, more common,
application-level
attacks that we encounter
is known as SQL injection.
Now, here in this picture,
you can see the happy packets
coming in and fulfilling orders.
But a SQL injection,
once that begins,
it is problematic for
two important reasons.
Important reason number one--
we have a DDoS attack
where it's trying
to actually deny service.
But more importantly, in
these types of attacks,
your data could potentially
also be at risk.
So coming back here
to our big screen,
you can see the happy
packets coming in.
But you can see here the
SQL injection attacks
coming in and interfering
with the orders on my servers
as they're going through here.
Now, both volumetric and
SQL injection attacks
are things that we can plan for
when we design our application.
So today we're happy to
announce Cloud Armor.
Cloud Armor has SQL
injection rules that
allow us to deploy in advance.
When this is deployed,
we can go out
and mitigate these
types of attacks
before they ever
endanger our application.
Both volumetric attacks
and SQL injection attacks
are ones that we can plan for
when we design our application.
There are more
sophisticated attacks that
require a reactive approach.
One of these we're
going to demonstrate
is going to be a
multi-vector attack.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So one
thing about vector attacks
are very interesting.
You have attackers
who use one or more
or even multiple
types of attacks
to try and overwhelm
your service.
So let's look at our service.
You can see that with our
Black Friday shoppers,
we have [INAUDIBLE] traffic.
But we also have
malicious traffic
that has some interesting
characteristics.
Look at the bottom
half of the screen.
What you notice in the
tiny island in the ocean
is a botnet attack.
Now, this attack has three
interesting characteristics.
First, it is originating
from the small island.
Second, the traffic
that's coming in
has this really
specific signature
inside the packet
in the traffic.
And the third thing is that it's
coming in from a specific type
of browser.
We can do something really
useful with this one.
We talked about Cloud
Armor, which provides
you application-level defense.
It also is underpinned by
a very sophisticated rules
language that lets you
build custom rules.
And so what we are
going to do now
to make sure our apps stay
good is to build a custom rule.
So when we deploy the custom
rule, what's going to happen
is the Cloud Armor
is going to look
for a specific pattern, which
is the specific signature,
the specific browser,
and then also
ensuring that this is
only traffic coming
from that specific island.
This way, you ensure that none
of your legitimate traffic
is blocked out but
your attackers are.
So here we launched the
Cloud Armor custom rule.
You can notice that
the botnet attack has
been easily mitigated against.
Everything looks good.
Our shopping app is happy.
And most importantly,
our users are happy.
We have an excellent
Black Friday.
We've made tons of profit.
We are now going to go
ship all of those products
to our happy shoppers.
And with all that,
we introduced you
to two interesting products--
the global load balancer
and Cloud Armor.
And we have an arsenal of other
products from our partners.
So with all of
these products, we
hope you'll build a
comprehensive solution.
Happy shopping and happy
keeping of your services
up and running.
Thank you.
NICK ORLOVE: And we
are back to being live.
Well, Prajakta, thanks so
much for showing that video.
I think it gave a really
good, high-level understanding
of how Cloud Armor works.
And I think it demonstrated
how relevant this product is.
As you saw in the example,
the retailer who basically has
to deliver a bunch of
products on Black Friday--
and we all know that Black
Friday can be one of the most
critical days of the year
for pulling in revenue--
was able to protect their
services using Cloud Armor.
So whether you're a retailer or
whether you're a gaming company
or what have you,
I can definitely
say that this would
be applicable.
So very exciting.
Now, Prajakta, can we go into
some of the nuts and bolts
of how the policies work?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: I knew
you would ask that.
NICK ORLOVE: I'm sure you did.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yeah.
So as you rightly pointed
out, first of all,
it is critical
for all customers,
whether you're a retailer,
gaming customer, and so on.
But what I wanted to do next was
to give a little bit of a peek
under the hood and explain how
is it that the framework is
built out, and
especially explain
by what we mean as a
policy-driven defense,
or policy-driven DDoS defense.
NICK ORLOVE: Absolutely.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So the way
Cloud Armor is laid out
is as a set of policies.
If you look at this
policy as an example,
the name of the policy-- there
are three policies in there.
You can probably read the
three policies in there.
Now when you think of
a policy, think of it
as a hierarchy of rules.
If you look on the
right hand side,
you can notice that
there is a set of rules.
At the end is always
a default truth.
Each rule itself is comprised
of a match condition
or a set of match conditions.
And then you'll
have some actions
that you'll take
on that as well.
And then you can take
this Cloud Armor policy
and you can go and connect it
or attach it to one or more
of your services.
So the moment you
do that, that's
when Cloud Armor kicks
in for your services.
You could choose to have a
custom policy per service,
or you could essentially
go and put the same policy
across all of your services.
So it's up to you.
NICK ORLOVE: Interesting.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: This is
a closer look at what's
inside a Cloud Armor rule.
So we spoke about the policy
being comprised of rule.
Inside the rule, essentially
you have a match condition.
And this could have
either one match condition
or there could be a set
of match conditions.
Once the traffic
matches the signature,
you obviously want
to tell us what you
want to do with the traffic.
So you know, it could be a
variety of actions in there,
as well.
You also want to tell us
where this rule should be
inserted inside the hierarchy.
So that is what the
priority tells you.
Preview is, again, another
interesting feature
where if you enable
preview, then
whatever action would have been
taken essentially gets locked.
But the Cloud Armor doesn't
actually take that action.
NICK ORLOVE: Oh, that's great.
You can actually see
what's going to happen.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Exactly.
And imagine you want
to try out a rule.
So that is when you
would go and configure it
in the preview mode.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: We wanted to
pick a framework for specifying
these rules using something
that will be open source,
as well as something
that's in use by some
of our other security products.
And that is why we picked
what is called the Common
Expressions Language, CEL.
It is hosted on GitHub, so you
can actually take a closer look
at it, as well.
But the entire specification
of Cloud Armor rules
is done using that.
And Firebase customers, if
you're an existing Firebase
customer, you've probably
already used it, as well.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, I've got
a couple questions, actually.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sure.
NICK ORLOVE: So first being,
I see that the actions either
allow or deny, which
is a little bit binary.
And I imagine that
some customers
would be interested in something
like throttling or rate
limiting.
Is that something that
you guys are considering
in product management?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yes,
that's a great question.
So today you can do allow, deny.
You can also specify
the codes with deny.
And we are actively working on
adding rate limiting, as well.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
I know some of my
customers are going
to be excited to hear that.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yeah, I think
it's a pretty useful feature
for a lot of customers.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
And then I also wanted to
ask, for the Common Expression
Language, how complex is that?
Is that something
that anyone can just
get going from the get go?
Or does it involve some
training, some complexity?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Actually, it
is fairly straightforward, very
intuitive to use.
And we are also publishing in
the Cloud Armor documentation
the rules for what you
would typically want to do.
Having said that, it has a lot
of features which-- actually,
let me show you what's in here.
NICK ORLOVE: OK, cool.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So let's
take a closer look at that.
When you think of Cloud Armor
rules language, the first thing
is, what are the things to
look for inside the traffic?
And to specify
those, you typically
want to look at IP addresses,
whether they are v4 or v6.
The HTTP headers,
for example, you
may want to look at the
geolocation of the client.
So each of these that
you see essentially
is looking at those specific
things inside the traffic.
That would be your attribute
or your set of attributes.
The second thing you
typically want to do
is combine one or
more attributes.
And that's where the
operators kick in.
So imagine this IP
address and not that geo.
So that's where you use the
operator "and," and also "not."
And then the last thing is we
have a very sophisticated set
of operations.
So for example-- actually,
it's not listed here.
But you can even do things
such as regular expressions.
You can do is low
or you can do upper.
So there's a whole
set of operations
that you can do to build
out, really, rituals.
And which ones of
these you use depends
on what it is that you're
trying to accomplish.
So that's roughly
what it looks like.
It's fairly human readable.
We will provide you an editor
inside our UI, so our Pantheon
UI.
And if you want to
automate it, you
have the gCloud CLI
and API, as well.
NICK ORLOVE: Great.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And
then as time goes by,
we'll try and give you
as many pre-canned rules
as we can so you
don't really have
to even look at the language
if you choose not to.
NICK ORLOVE: Love it.
Cool.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
let's run through some
of the use cases that drove
creation of Cloud Armor.
The most popular use case
that we initially started with
was essentially a blacklist
and whitelist for your traffic.
In this example, our customer
wants to only allow, let's say,
traffic from 9.9.9.0/24.
So you would put a rule
which looks for that IP
and then you would
put whatever action
it is that you want to take.
This could be either
allow, this could be deny.
And you could also turn it on
in the preview mode, as well.
This is supported
both for IPv4 and IPv6
because our global load balancer
supports IPv6 clients, as well.
And then this could typically
very likely in many cases
this specific condition could be
combined with other conditions,
as well.
One of the most popular usage
of this specific feature
is if you're using a
third party service
or you're using one of
our partner services.
And let's say you're
scrubbing your traffic
through the partner.
Without this feature, even
if you scrub the traffic
through the partner,
you need something
at the edge of our network
which says only allow traffic
in from the partner and deny
all of the traffic that's not
scrubbed through the partner.
So this is where you would also
leverage the whitelist feature.
And that's one of the most
popular use cases for this one.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: The
other popular one
is geobased access control.
So you want to
bring in essentially
traffic from certain geos
and block from other geos.
This is where, again,
you would use Cloud Armor
with checking for the region
code, which checks for the geo.
You don't have to worry
about the IPs and so on.
You just specify the code
which is the ISO alpha 2 code.
So in this case, it's
using a region code as US.
So it takes a whole lot
of toil from your end
in mapping any IPs to geo.
You just use geo directly.
The third one, which is, again,
another popular use case,
is customers asking for
WAF-like functionality,
more specifically for defense
against application event
attacks, things such as
cross-site scripting or SQL
injection that we spoke about.
And we have pre-canned
rules for it.
So you don't need to worry about
how to craft a defense for it.
As you can see, it's a single
rule which, in this case,
as far as SQL injection.
And there's a similar rule
for cross-site scripting.
And then we'll continue
to add to this rule set
so you don't have to
worry about crafting
these rules on your end.
The fourth one is what
you saw before when we
did the nice Black Friday demo.
In this case, what
you're essentially doing
is taking a set of
parameters, and you are
crafting your own custom rules.
These could be for
day-zero attacks.
These could be for customized
access for your services.
And we have several
partners who are actually
using this to build out
their own products, as well.
So there are several uses
cases for this language.
And in this case, it's
looking for traffic
that's originating from US
where the user agent contains
bad port and also the
cookie is a specific value.
And it's likely going
to drop that traffic.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
Yeah that's always
on everyone's mind
is how do we prevent
zero-day attacks?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yeah.
NICK ORLOVE: That is something
very difficult to accomplish.
So I'm glad that
Google's gotten into it.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yeah,
this is actually
building out the framework.
The whole thing is,
anytime you want
to defend against
an attack, you need
to be able to craft these
really custom signatures.
And to do that,
first of all, you
need a very flexible language
where you can express what
it is that you want to block.
So this actually goes a
long way in doing that.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
One of the things
is when you actually
do all of this,
you do want to make
sure that you're
able to see what is
blocked or what is allowed.
And we show these
VR Stackdriver logs.
So if you zoomed in on
this one, what it's doing
is this was essentially
an SQL injection
attack that was blocked.
And it is telling you that
the action taken was denied.
It tells you what
policy was matched.
It also tells you the
priority, which basically maps
to the rule that blocked it.
And then it also
gives a string, which
is denied by security
policy, which
gives you some more additional
details about the block itself.
So this is very critical
because a lot of customers
would want to see what is
blocked and what is allowed,
and then also to see
that the policies are
working as intended.
The last one is actually a
very interesting use case.
And we have another product
called identity of their proxy
and that will essentially
work with user identities
and will tell you if the
traffic is authenticated.
So can we access
a service or not?
So it's basically
identity-based access control.
The nice thing is that it
works with the HTTP/HTTPS load
balancer.
And so you can use it in
conjunction with Cloud Armor.
So imagine you wanted to say
something to the effect of,
only let the traffic
in if, let's say,
the user is coming from US
and the user is authenticated
or has been-- it's allowed
to access the service
based on identity.
And that is when you would
turn on both Cloud Armor
and identity of error proxy.
And it gives you a really
good set of, again,
rules that you can deploy to
see what kind of access control
you want to do.
So you can layer on--
like, think of it as the stack.
You've got layer three,
layer four, layer seven.
And with identity of error
proxy working in conjunction
with Cloud Armor,
you have a layer x
on top, which is
essentially identity.
So it's a very powerful stack
that you have at your disposal.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
I can definitely see how
this would be incredibly
applicable for companies
that might have employees who
are going on the road or getting
into airplanes, traveling,
et cetera, because it would
be really difficult to say,
all right, this employee,
only accept their IP address
when they're in California.
But when they go
on a sales trip,
it would be difficult to
change the rules automatically.
So the combination of
Cloud Armor plus identity
of error proxy just makes
it incredibly powerful.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's true.
That's true.
NICK ORLOVE: So I hear
you have a demo for us.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So, yeah.
Because I knew you would ask me
a question, so I have it ready.
So what I wanted to
do is we showed you
what it looks like from
a customer's perspective
using the Black Friday example.
We showed you some of
the constructs that
actually make up Cloud Armor.
What I wanted to show you
is a demo and then also
show you a little bit
of the configuration
or under the hood.
So I thought we should
pick-- let's pick the three
typical attacks
that you can expect
customers to be worried about.
And so let's go back in here.
OK.
So the first one essentially
is the DDoS attack.
Now, in this case, the
way we have set it up
is we have two projects.
One is the attacker project.
One is the defender project.
In the attacker project--
and we have set up this
tool called Metasploit
and some of our own home grown
systems to go launch attacks.
The other side in
the defender project
is where we'll go and
configure a set of things
to defend against the attacks.
So the first one is an
infrastructure DDoS attack.
Now, let's go to
the defense side.
If you notice the red
thing, that is basically
your attack traffic.
And you can see that things--
like, you can see
that line go up.
NICK ORLOVE: And these are real
data points, not anything--
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yes.
And I'll show you the
stuff behind the good.
NICK ORLOVE: That's cool.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Now, if
you look at this one,
if you look in here,
all we need to do
for this one is turn on
the global HTTP/HTTPS load
balancer.
That's all this command does.
So when I click it, you can
notice that the load balancer
got deployed.
And you can see that
the line is essentially
going down, which means our
attack traffic is going down.
It's now almost mitigated.
The second attack, if you
remember we spoke about,
was SQL injection.
Now again, this
is using the tool.
This is not as much about
volume but essentially just
exploiting the
SQL set of traffic
and then injecting a
malicious stuff in there.
So again, Metasploit generates
an SQL injection attack.
And on the defense side, this
is where Cloud Armor kicks in.
So when we click that button,
what it's going to deploy
is a security policy, which is
turning on essentially the SQL
injection defense.
So let's turn that on.
And you can notice that the
attack traffic has gone down.
The last one is the one that
we spoke about earlier, which
is the multi-vector attack.
So you could have either
infrastructure in this
or you could have
different types of attacks
within a single attack
or from a single entity.
And let's launch
this attack in here.
Let's assume that this attack,
the signature of the attack
is traffic coming in from
US with user-agent bad bot
and then a specific
type of cookie.
So we would put in a
rule that actually does
these three things, looks
for these three things,
and it denies the traffic.
So again, the red is
the attacker traffic.
And when I deny, this you can
see that the attack traffic
is going down.
So the attack is mitigated.
And just to show that
this is all real,
let me show you the project
that sits behind this.
So this is the defender
side of things.
These are our Stackdriver logs.
So when you look in
here, you can see
what is getting logged in here.
And then you know basically
what happened, et cetera.
So this is where you look at
those logs that we spoke about.
And then the actual
configuration
would be somewhere in here where
if you go to the networking
side of things, this
is security policies
is where all of these policies
are actually configured.
And you know, there's a
bunch of interesting stuff
to do in there, especially if
you start configuring rules.
When we spoke about
the rules language,
this is the advanced mode.
And this is where you would
go and use the language
to create your rules.
NICK ORLOVE: Man, talk
about real time protection.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yeah.
So this is actually where--
you know, it
basically is the time
where I ask you the question.
And I say, Nick, so what do
you think of Cloud Armor?
NICK ORLOVE: I think it's an
incredibly powerful product.
It is definitely one
of the amazing tools
that we can put in our customers
toolbelt, security protection
tools.
And so what I really took away
was four key things, first
being Cloud Armor does a
phenomenal job of mitigating
DDoS attacks, whether
that's just a TCP SYN
flood, amplification attacks,
or fragmentation attacks,
we really have our
customers' back
and make sure that
they're protected.
Also, I love that the complex
or the comprehensive rules
allow you to protect on all
sorts of different areas,
whether it's a specific to
IP address, geolocation,
custom matches, L3
through L7, it's
very enabling to give
this to our customers
and let them create and
set their own rules.
Also, I really like that
this not only depends
on the infrastructure attacks,
but also application of attacks
so that Google supports our
customers in their applications
that they're trying to run.
And then lastly,
what solution would
exist without some kind of way
of monitoring and making sure
that what you've deployed
is actually working?
So I love that this is real time
and we can enable our customers
to do that.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Perfect.
That's good.
So that brings us to almost
the end of the presentation.
We wanted to make sure you had
a look at the load balancer,
the network, Cloud Armor.
But I think our biggest
endorsements generally always
come from seeing customers
actually use these products
and then find value
in the products.
And Evernote, in fact, in
2016 moved to Google Cloud.
And one of the strong
drivers for them
was that they could not
only match the security that
was on prem, but
then also get several
of these other constructs
that they could not probably
have on prem.
And they're also one of
our users of Cloud Armor.
And they've been
using it to protect
internet-facing services.
So with this, we come to the
end of this demo slash webinar.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah.
But we really
appreciate everyone
who's been writing in
those live Q&A questions.
So we'll take just a second,
compile those questions,
and we will be back.
Awesome.
Well, thank you
so much, everyone,
for writing in your questions.
We really appreciate it.
So Prajakta, you're
in the hot seat.
Have some questions for you.
First off, what
types of companies
are going to be
interested in Cloud Armor?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: I think that's
a great question, and actually
the first question
that we should answer.
I would say any
company, organization
that's delivering
anything that's internet
facing in Google
cloud is going to be
interested in Cloud Armor.
One of the examples that we
describe was the Black Friday.
So we do have a large
set of retailers
that are deploying Cloud
Armor already, testing it
out and also deploying it
for production traffic.
Similarly, we have a large
set of gaming customers
that are interested in this.
We have financial customers
and also several large
and mid-sized enterprises
because one of the nice things
is, as enterprises move to
the cloud, they have fast--
you know, started thinking
about purveys of security.
And this plays into
essentially securing
any of their
internet-facing services.
So at this point I would say,
almost everybody who has,
I think, any plans of delivering
an internet-facing service
or is delivering an
internet-facing service would
be interested in Cloud Armor.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
Basically everyone
who has a website.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And more.
NICK ORLOVE: Yeah, and more.
And more.
I also love that you mentioned
Project Shield a little bit
earlier.
So besides just the
for profit companies,
we also support
nonprofits, so that's cool.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
Actually, that is true.
So one of the things
that I probably
didn't speak enough about it--
but we do have Project
Shield, which is essentially
a pro bono service.
It defends all of the
journalists who are--
maybe they're not in
democratic nations,
or they're under fire
for publishing posts.
And we use the same Google
infrastructure to actually
go defend their web sites.
So we can actually
go and continue
to support freedom of
speech and expression.
Yeah, that's a great point.
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
OK.
Well, let's move
on to the next one.
So I know that Google
is very focused
around machine learning and AI.
For anyone who joined
us at Google IO,
I think that was pretty evident.
So what are Cloud
Armor's strategies
for incorporating ML and AI?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: That's
a great question again.
So ML or Machine
Learning, deep learning,
these are basically embedded
in Google's infrastructure
at all layers.
And so the things that
are under the hood already
incorporate machine
learning and AI.
One of the things that
we want to do is-- so
what is our vision for Cloud
Armor, or any security system,
for that matter?
You want to make that system
more and more intelligent,
to a point where there is no
human that's crafting rules.
Or essentially, there
is not a third party
that's sitting and monitoring
you to craft rules.
At least something should be
aiding them in going and doing
those things.
And so our vision
for Cloud Armor
or for a lot of the
security systems is,
can we become intelligent
enough to predict attacks?
And then, can they actually
go and mitigate those attacks?
And there are several
initiatives where these things
already exist under the hood.
But a lot of our
focus for Cloud Armor
will be actually
building it out in a way
that our customers can
leverage it, as well.
So it is on our roadmap.
NICK ORLOVE: Cool.
That is good to hear.
The next question is
absolutely applicable.
I've had a couple
customers asking about it.
So let's say that
you're a customer.
You already have a partner
who's helping you with this.
Can they use Cloud Armor in
tandem with that partner?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Definitely.
So we have several use cases.
It would essentially
boil down to what
it is that you want, what are
the capabilities that you're
looking for?
We have several customers who
use their favorite partner
and then they combine that
with, let's say, blacklists,
whitelist, using Cloud Armor.
They definitely leverage
the DDoS infrastructure,
DDoS defense that comes
with global load balancing.
And then they mix and
match all of these.
So for instance, there might
be some sophisticated or custom
WAF rules that the
partner has built.
You can definitely use those in
conjunction with Cloud Armor.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
And can you share any
details around performance?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sure.
So one of the things
where we always
do well on all of Google
Cloud Services is performance.
And the reason for that
is these are architected
to be distributed systems.
And so if you think of
the global HTTP/HTTPS load
balancer, we published a
blog post two years back
where we tested it with about
a million queries per second,
which is huge.
And beyond that, we
stopped, because that's
way more than what a typical
customer can expect to see.
The same applies
for Cloud Armor,
as well, because it works with
the global HTTP/HTTPS load
balancer.
And so the global
HTTP/HTTPS performance,
again, is applicable to
Cloud Armor, as well.
NICK ORLOVE: OK.
And then one last
question, real quick,
can you describe the
pricing of Cloud Armor?
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
the pricing will
go in effect at [INAUDIBLE].
But right now we have
already published it.
So it's $5 for a policy.
It's $1 for a rule, irrespective
of what kind of rule it is.
And then it's $0.75
for a million queries.
We will be publishing
more details
as we get close to
the [INAUDIBLE]..
NICK ORLOVE: Awesome.
Well, thank you
everyone for joining us.
Prajakta, huge thank you for
joining us for the CE Chat.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: It's
been my pleasure.
Thank you, everyone.
Thanks, Nick.
NICK ORLOVE: Make
sure you stick around.
Our next session is going
to be around Cloud Composer.
If you're using anything big
data, any complex pipelines,
you'll definitely want
to tune in for that.
Thanks, everyone.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Thank you.
[THEME MUSIC]